[Music]
[Applause]
sean payton former saints head coach
does that sound strange to hear
actually it's the first time uh
i heard that and it sounded a little odd
yes
when did you realize though
that you were getting close to a
decision about stepping away from the
saints
i think probably the latter part of the
season um
and
when we finished
you always try to kind of avoid you know
something like that when it's raw right
when the season's over with and you know
i spent a couple days i i spoke with
mickey our general manager mrs benson
and
and then uh
you know typically a staff has a week
off after the season before you start on
the senior bowl and the scouting and and
so we all kind of had that vacation and
but i'd say honestly the last the last
part of the season
um there wasn't one game there wasn't
one specific moment it
it just felt uh like this was going to
be the time
who tried to talk you out of this
well
mickey who's a dear friend uh our j our
gm and i spoke for an hour and a half um
this is the this was right after the
season ended so this is
you know the week prior to the wild card
round
he was good i mean he understood it
we've been together two of us 16 years
mrs benson was the one that really
was adamant you know that i take a week
away and and
um and don't give her an early decision
um
[Music]
and then outside of that you know dennis
lausch our president the same way um
you know both my kids were were all ears
you know they really wanted to be
supportive and and
you know they there's a
we it's we've heard burnout before i i
don't know that it's that but
when you're someplace for 16 years
15 seasons um
you know over a period of time that
you're you're uh
you're almost ready for another
challenge and you don't know the thing
about it is that there was a week or two
leading up to this and then at the at
the point where i stepped away
there was this discussion that hey he's
going to go into tv and i'd like to do
that
and yet i hadn't heard from anybody you
know you know there was this well he's
already
and i'm like
ouch kind of hard to go in if nobody's
asking you to come in no one's asking so
i
fortunately the the day of uh after the
press conference um we received a number
of calls and
but you know there's every once in a
while i think it's all right to step
outside be a little uncomfortable in in
uh
and i think that that had a lot to do
with it
do you want to do studio or would you
like to be part of a game broadcast
that's a great question i i don't i
don't know uh honestly i'd like
maybe some expert to say this is what i
think you should do
um because i have no idea
well here's the here's the problem and
and drew ran into this in the playoff
game that he did like you got to be
to the point
you got 20 seconds 15 seconds
you got you have a play clock
you know that you had have to adhere to
yeah can you do that can you
compartmentalize
say something that is going to be
tangent to what's going on get the hell
out of the way let the play develop now
what did you just see that we didn't see
and yeah i think so
um
absolutely i had a guy in a production
meeting this year from one of the
networks
asked me to um
hey
when you're taking us through this
take us through it like you were you
were helping our moms or explaining it
to our mothers you know where everyone
can understand and i and i think that
in
in a year where we lost probably the
best to ever do it relative to the
masses in john madden
you know when john
there's generations that think of john
either as a coach that wasn't me
an announcer that was me
and then certainly the madden game which
is my son
um
he had a a a great way
in 10 seconds
or even less than that to say hey they
pushed harder here and that's why they
gained three yards yeah it it's it seems
simple but it's not and and the great
ones you know romo does an unbelievable
job collinsworth does an unbelievable
job troy does it's you gotta see it
say it
get out of the way
and then let your play-by-play voice
call the action
now you have to clean up the mess right
after that of why it happened or you
know it didn't happen
yeah absolutely
and
sometimes what i observed from afar
is
and and with all of the the guys you
just mentioned
um
i i've done some some studio work before
a super bowl or studio on set work
before uh
whatever a playoff round and you have
your topic and you know the the person
in charge is the one that's really
directing traffic they've got a hard job
we all wait for our little point you
know they they throw us the pass and we
shoot we shoot a shot and
then we root for that to happen in the
game and then when it doesn't happen in
the game the coaches are all messed up
why didn't that happen i predicted it
um
and so
yeah i i think sometimes
i would guess one of the bigger mistakes
would be uh we're not getting paid by
the word
yes like sometimes it's right there for
us to watch
and uh
and and you see that
you know what's interesting
i i think one of the better compliments
would be i can't recall who called the
game
my dad used to say you know
a sign of someone that was well-dressed
he couldn't remember what he wore but we
can certainly remember when we don't
like what we hear well it's like an
umpire in baseball if i don't know your
name you probably had a pretty good game
uh we're talking to
sean payton the former saints head coach
i was curious about the state of the
saints and the role that that played in
your decision salary cap issues you
don't have a franchise quarterback you
don't know what's happening with michael
thomas you somehow squeezed nine wins
out of this roster which was amazing but
what role did that play
in you deciding that you wanted to step
away
you know i i
i've been asked that question but i
would i would say it had little to do
with this decision and
here's where i'm going
we had 58 we were the first team to ever
have 58 starters in a season that was a
record so the prior record was 57 that
team i'm not sure who won three games
there was somebody that had 56 that won
five games
um we won nine games
with with 58 starters and we won because
our defense is playing it at an
outstanding level
um we didn't turn the ball over
offensively and granted we we played
four different quarterbacks
but
we're built through the offensive line
mike thomas will be coming back off an
injury and in
we have a salary cap issue but we had
that same cap issue in a different even
in a more dramatic fashion heading into
last season then you look at our
division
because you want to win
and you look at carolina
and then you look at atlanta
and
now well i'm okay with that
and then you look over at tampa bay and
man there's going to be some shuffling
of the guard there they won the division
but they didn't beat us
um
so i i think yeah there's no utopia when
you walk into one of these jobs and then
me leaving i don't think dan
i don't think
it was
it was because of
the current i would say that almost was
a was something that was weighing with
me because you don't get a defense like
this yeah often you know it took a long
time yeah
how many teams have reached out to you
not one
no networks
now well they they would have to reach
out to the scenes and and look you you
know this
you can have a back door
hey would you have any interest um
that's happened maybe
with a couple a couple clubs but i i'm
not i'm not looking at that path right
now i at some point i don't think i'm
finished coaching but
um i was excited to to get two or three
calls and texts from from people in the
television industry
but you have had teams back channel
third party
uh the two
and and when i say that
if i guess will you tell me
yeah you no because there's only
wait you said yes
if i don't
when i say that all i'm saying is
somebody who's close to someone but man
you'd be really good here um this is
only we're 24 or 48 hours
remove from it and that's not my plan um
my my plan is for someone to tell me we
think you'd be good at play but or not
play by play but in game analysis or in
studio we think you'd be good at
this
and uh we'd like you to to come try it
and i'd be excited because there's a
part of you that also wants to um
to listen and learn again and not be the
one directing
just
how can i be great at some at something
different than coaching
and then teach me
the bears and the cowboys
no no
oh that's worth stopping oh oh okay
well here's the other thing sean
you can't master it in one year
if you're gonna do this
you know you you have to go all in and
do it
because jason whitton wasn't ready to do
this he he he needed to he needed other
reps to maybe get to a certain point but
if you're going to commit to this
then you got to look at it and say i'm
committed for
two years three years because if i'm
hiring you
and it's going to be in a booth uh you
know studio interchangeable but in a
booth you're calling a game and if
you're there with joe buck for fox
then i want to know you want to be there
and we we develop and even you know jim
nance said this to us earlier in the
week this was the first game he did with
tony romo where he thought
the five years we've been together that
we
we called our best game
and they're
among the elite to ever do it but that's
the commitment you're going to have to
make
no i i understand and
i i think that's kind of exciting i i i
said look
i'm my coach again because i don't want
to say
i'm never doing this and then someday
somebody say well this is what he told
us i thought you know
that happened so often with coaches that
um
when madden left after 10 years my
understanding was he was pursued twice
you know and then finally
took that job with cbs
and uh
yeah i i don't think it's possible to
dabble in something like that and it's
not possible for me to dabble in
anything
and
um and i've i've listen i've watched
these progressions
and these hires and i would i would say
i agree with you
with what you're saying whitten didn't
have a great surrounding cast either
but interesting to watch tony's
because the one thing that that
that's apparent is until
that individual's on camera for a game
or two it's hard to predict
how they're going to be
and how the television is going to
receive them like
you know
it it's probably a little bit like a
first round pick or a second round pick
we think
we've got a vision and yet i'm sure
there's been a lot of misses
and then i'm sure there have been some
other ones that oh this guy was better
than we ever expected
yeah it's that ability to be able to
predict what's going to happen and and
it helps being a quarterback
you know with with peyton doing it or
romo doing that that that you're aware
that hey
you do your homework if you were
coaching against this team like sure
that's that's your process probably is
like this is what we always prepared for
this is what they like to do this is
what i would be calling like those are
the kind of things where you can rely on
all of those years of being a head coach
and assistant coach
yeah
look exactly because when i watch a game
which isn't often but when you watch a
game in a television manner last weekend
was a great weekend of football
you're thinking situationally 13 seconds
this is what we're gonna
have to do
to win this game on defense or you're
thinking how the hell did that happen
how the hell now i'm asking you as an
analyst
yeah how the hell did the
chiefs do that in 13 seconds
they did it because defensively
buffalo played outside outside technique
in a zone coverage defending the
sidelines the problem was kansas city
had timeouts and you can't do that when
a team has timeouts so every receiver
entered
entered
the defensive backfield with free access
particularly their better receivers and
it just can't happen and it didn't you
know there's a there's a four-man rush
but they're protecting the sidelines
when kansas city city didn't need to get
to the sidelines kansas city could go
anywhere they wanted that's good but i
would i would have cut that down to
about 15 seconds and you would have you
would have squeezed it in there yeah you
know so then ask me the end of the
cowboys game and let me see if i can do
this better okay
uh what did the cowboys do wrong in this
situation
well look they're trying to get in feel
they're trying to get in touchdown range
and they ran a draw we typically would
throw a pass and down down ultimately i
think two further two more steps for for
dak
uh he's got to slide a little quicker
he's up paul has to go to the umpire
then let's go
um
we can never hand the ball to the center
okay i like that
you got to speak in 15 second sound
bites you you should actually practice
this
you know somebody ask you a question
give them 15 seconds
and and have that clock in your head
you know if pizza is delivered
15 seconds that's it
drew brees calls you 15 seconds per
answer
what are you going to do all day today
well i've got a list um
i've got uh
i've got to do some packing um i'm
actually moving into another
um house here in new orleans um
you're going to stay there in new
orleans
well yeah i mean i'm going to have a
presence here we'll always have a
presence here and and we're moving in
from a bigger house into uh
uh
like a condominium development
so i've got a
number of things i've got to do
relative to packing um i'm going to stop
there because i'm at 15 seconds okay
that's good that's good and you got a
movie tomorrow night that comes or
tomorrow comes out on netflix
i you know i've been asked so much about
it and i'm i'm really excited for for
that group for adam sandler and his his
team and chris tyton who
is my daughter's boyfriend
um
i've had zero
input in in i've helped him
with the story uh i've got a small
little cameo
and i'm excited like you are just to
watch it put it on and see what it see
what it looks like it you know it sounds
like it's going to be funny in in along
the lines of uh
the bad news bears
um and what i say in my cameo just so
you know i don't believe what i said
okay i'm an actor because i
i was a little critical about you and
your ego
ah i got it i so well i'm a janitor in
this movie
and so as a janitor i'm not going to be
offended about what you say about kevin
james playing sean payton exactly right
um could we get the visor from your last
game
yeah
we like to put it in the man cave if i
could
i like it i i will make sure and and i
know where it's at um we will send that
to you that
might not be the last visor you wear as
a head coach in the nfl
well i yeah there's a chance
look if if this television thing goes
well and i don't think they're going to
want me an advisor
[Laughter]
maybe the first game you wear a visor
just to let them know you're coaching
you know you pay attention to all these
things and romo and nance have the
matching cbs suits and then certainly
uh buck and aikman go a certain
direction
and then uh nbc everyone's got their own
little yeah their own little twist to it
it is interesting to watch and
it's it's those first two weekends wild
card
or divisional round
where one of the networks has two games
and you get
and i don't want to say this in any but
you get the other team
and you're watching a playoff game and
you're like hey why do i have the other
team it's a playoff game and you
understand that obviously they've got
two games
uh good luck with this and if i can help
let me know
you know i appreciate it yeah i uh
i appreciate our friendship and working
relationship too all through these years
thank you sean uh we appreciate it good
luck all right thank you sean payton the
former saints head coach we'll take a
break back after this